so i have three different asteroids over
here and they have different masses and
we'll talk a lot more about what mass
means but one way to think about it is
how much stuff there is there there's
other ways to think about it and so
let's say that this first asteroid is
twice the mass of either of these two
smaller ones and these two smaller ones
have the same mass
now we've attached the back of a rocket
to each of these asteroids in fact this
one over here has two rockets and we're
going to assume that all of the rockets
are equivalent and we ignite them all
and so they all exert the same force
each on the asteroid so for example we
have a net force acting leftward on this
large asteroid we have the same net
force acting on this smaller asteroid
also going to the left and on this other
smaller asteroid we have two times that
net force acting to the left so what i
want you to do is pause this video and
think about which of these asteroids is
going to be accelerated the most and
which of these asteroids is going to be
accelerated the least
alright so you might have an intuition
that the larger the force the more
acceleration you might see so let me
write it like this so you might get a
sense that if you increase your force
that that's also going to increase your
acceleration
and it does turn out that that is indeed
the case
now the other notion that you might have
is that the more of the stuff that there
is the more mass that you have the
harder it is to accelerate it so if your
mass is larger then your acceleration is
lower and it turns out that these things
are all proportional
so for example if we just compare these
two masses right over here they have the
same net force acting on it and i keep
saying net force that means you just net
out all of the forces acting in a
certain dimension for example if i had
another identical rocket acting in the
opposite direction they would net out
and this asteroid right over here
wouldn't be accelerated at all
but going back to our example here we
have the same net force acting on each
of these asteroids but the first
asteroid has twice the mass of the
second asteroid so how do you think the
accelerations will relate
well as you might imagine the
acceleration on the larger asteroid is
going to be half the acceleration on
this asteroid or another way to think
about it this asteroid is going to have
twice the acceleration as this first
asteroid and that's because it has half
the mass
and one way you can relate force mass
and acceleration and this is one of the
most important equations in all of
physics is that force
is going to be equal to
mass
times acceleration or i could say the
magnitude of the force is equal to the
mass times the magnitude of the
acceleration
so notice in this example right over
here our forces are the same but the
masses are different if i have half the
mass as i have over here i'm going to
have twice the acceleration and that
might make intuitive sense if you've
ever tried to apply the same force to
something that has a small mass versus
something that has a large mass
now if we compare these two asteroids
they have the same mass here
but the force here the net force acting
in that left direction is double so if
you double the force don't change the
mass well then you're going to have
twice the acceleration
so this is going to have twice the
acceleration of this one and this one's
going to have twice the acceleration of
that one but the important thing to
realize is how force mass and
acceleration are connected